[Music]
and that escalated quickly news so
quickly then that sounds like mine and
Bart's fights no I'm fine
who escalates it what submitted by that
[ __ ] dad man a man was arrested for
giving his girlfriend a wet willy
what yeah can't do that anymore I mean
how hard my god tip woulda totally
arrested me and I would have been in
trouble home from digger party what'd he
do spit on his dick and then [ __ ] try
to poke it in her ear yeah was it with
his dick or something yeah
just picturing that I know oh but your
boyfriend spit on his dick and I go baby
me yeah put in your ear come on he's
done a bunch of [ __ ] with his balls and
pick on my face exactly see ya I thought
it was your face doing stuff to my balls
and it yeah yeah or else it's like one
person just closes their eyes and laid
down and the other person's rubbing the
ball sack all over then that's him doing
something if it's one individual laying
down and closing on the other
individuals rubbing the ball [ __ ] and
balls in her face yeah I wonder what
individuals would what I like talking
about [ __ ] like it's a legal proceeding
and at that point the individual smile
inserted his it's always like the old
boy took on doctor's office for
everything all right so this took place
in Florida and so this the victim is
saying that when she came home from work
that her live-in boyfriend Joseph was so
drunk he was lying on the floor and then
that when he woke up that the two began
to argue and then that he became rude
and then that's when the woman decided
to leave home with her daughter to go to
another person's home but then the
boyfriend tagged along and then while
they were there the victim said that he
kept drinking and he came more and more
belligerent and then on the way back to
the car he started to get all grabby
with her and then that he gave her a wet
willy and then that's when she called
the police such a violent man he could
have done it violently he's like you're
not going anywhere till I'll give you a
wet willy you could have been yelling at
raucous and embarrassing her
he's laughing
know your place I wouldn't never to
think to do a wet willy in the middle of
an argument no it's pretty good like a
wet willy is not something that I do out
of anger about what Willy's in general
do you think she's like acting like a
[ __ ] child or you're like berating
her or whatever yeah oh really oh really
it could be a little baby here though
baby
yeah well at that boys [ __ ] in close
least when they got back home he they
kept raging and throwing things around
that's when she called the and the baby
is there the whole time kicking at all
while she talked off the baby at the
whole thing could click Bailey dude I
was told that this was a wet willy
situation that escalated it was no but I
was told that this is a wet willy that
initiated at the police call where did
the wet willy happen when did when where
do the wet willy happened TIFF answer
the [ __ ] question TIFF
he got charged with second degree
battery after doing that because of the
wet willy or because of their reporting
it their reporting it because of the wet
willy I also think this guy should go to
jail cuz you should not I think what
Willy should build out but not in the
middle of throwing things cuz that's
like being bipolar throwing things where
though you can't well you can't in a
trash you can't throw it against the
wall and then tickler and then continue
to throw other things does your behavior
has to be consistent if it's America you
can throw anything you want you can but
you can't throw it in the middle like I
can't punch a girl in the face and then
give her a wet willy
that's what silly no punching girl the
face I agree yeah that should be okay
you should be able to throw anything you
want in your own home as per the
American Constitution but you can't do
that wet willy in the middle of throwing
all those things why can't you do what's
confusing the Constitution says you can
do that's like that's like arguing and
then taking a bite of a doughnut and
then going back and [ __ ] party with
your armpit and then you're fighting and
then you grab a mug and you throw it
against the wall that's psychotic
none of that is illegal but it's the
combination of things well they're
punching if you punch somebody in yes
that's psychological cuz it's like
grabbing a girl's butt cheeks not
illegal but she says no and they mean
grab it that is illegal
no governor's
I could grab the butt cheeks no no right
yeah your girl yeah true
she's your legal property under the TV I
understand we both we agree we listen
yeah yeah oh wow he looks like he likes
drugs like Jersey Shore who's that guy
same guy have you got older [ __ ] Wow
cheers the same guy the same guy what
are you serious go back are you serious
wait so wait what it is the same guy
wait please the other guy though same as
the other guy in the store there's no
other guy in the story no other day so
then it's him same ears how did his nose
get bigger no how did he get older wait
I think you got a reporting I think it
looks like the same guy well the
eyebrows I brought the same no he's got
a scar on one on no now is I think that
was a barber cut are you guys as
confused as I am now is the intentional
cut for his eyebrows how come he's more
tanned hair it's just a different
lighting mugshots have we different
lighting ones in Jersey Shore another
one one's got a warm sunlight and then
the other one's a mugshot ones Jersey
Shore and the other ones Minneapolis the
reason why I knew this was the same guy
those cuz they had the same mold what
and one he knows taking the picture suck
in his face in alright the other one
he's getting the mugshot he hates it
it's not fun Mike Schadt it's funny cuz
he's like what the [ __ ] for why Willie
what exactly all idea was the we're
winning
oh yeah that's pretty funny I think the
how was the Willie your honor how what
was the Willie that's what I want to
know I pretty wet if it was weighted
enough to press charges
significantly wet then let's have a
conversation about it what if you almost
popped her freaking eardrum cuz it was
like jabbing it in their sole assault
what a deadly finger that's another
point see I want to show the information
before we condemn a man to prison what
about the fact that he was drunk in
front of his daughter he could be drunk
in America in front your daughter
he's been especially if you know it's
child endangerment he claimed that he
wasn't drunk there's a high tolerance I
would say that I was drugged because
anybody that's wet will
right in the middle gotta be draw if
you're sober then you're just [ __ ]
crazy man
I can't believe she called the cops on
that's [ __ ] up as hell what did the
thighs just a prank bro I mean it [ __ ]
he's just wet well you know I don't know
no I'm open to it I'm open to it also
keep in mind that this man was already
on the floor drunk passed out how
annoying is this girlfriend that walked
through the door that made him get all
the way up to even get into a final on
the floor yeah it would take a lot for
me to get up she was walking away so
that he can have his peace and quiet
yeah but then he tagged along no way
no but then he got up and they started
arguing yeah if he was at peace on the
floor like Bart said mind his own
business she had to be so extra annoying
for him to interrupt his soup I walked
in there and started like telling him
what to do because guys can't live
without their mommies and then their
significant other becomes their mommies
so then as soon as the mom he was
leaving the picture he's like oh no my
mommy's leaving and then he started
patting oh she's like so I was at this
door and then like this girl I asked
this girl she could get me as high as
three and she said they don't have any
and I said can you look in the back and
he's like and she didn't and I'm like
well you didn't even look at the back
and then she's like you're not even
answering me is like no I'm this into
you I'm just like laying down and then
she's like whoa I just feel like I'm
just talking myself like why I just
wanted to share this thing happened to
me at the store and it needs all night
shut up darling you always do this [ __ ]
is this trying to sober up no Darlene
Darlene he's like I was talking to you
didn't hear me he's like let me help you
clean it out yeah that's probably what
happened what happened that's so rude
even if it happened like that I'm just
so sick and tired a reasonable drunk
people going down for pretty reasonable
drunken behavior for a reasonable at
Willie's he was this sobering up he
doesn't get my sympathy at all he's a
prick because he's a man no because he's
a prick but what if the roles the roles
were reversed what if it was a drunk
lady on the ground
passed out feeling all comfortable and
the guy and the guy comes in
yeah talking about his hard day at
working and knowing her ass and she has
to get up yeah it's still eight do what
if the chick went Willie's the guy you'd
be making fun of the guy cuz he called
the cops for getting wet Willie I would
have feel sorry for [ __ ] because you
know what does it double standard ya
know put your [ __ ] on me it's funnier
when guys get abused by girls no it's
way funnier no look if it's a if it's
like a little kid getting abused by a
woman then no it's not if it's like a
big ass woman like me and a smile even
more funny cuz it looks like it looks
like you're picking on a little boy yeah
oh you're an adult so it looks like
you're picking on a [ __ ]
if he looks like he plays the cello and
like a [ __ ] band or what do you call
it a concert band concert if they let it
go let it go pretty view of yours that
stature about yeah well he looks like a
man of small stature who plays a big
instrument and then you're whaling on
his ass I laugh even more yeah funny you
and your girlfriend's get on man no not
physically no no no we're talking about
his house basically it's funny
physically abusing this [ __ ] is not
funny
that's just Talent if Gio was reading my
ass it up like on the floor curled up
that'd be really funny that makes me so
sad be laughing and crying at the same
it's even funnier because Bart is a big
guy and he's on he's like it's really
funny it's almost like a big Great Dane
being punked by a chihuahua growing up
like in school and stuff like when they
have a crush on you you know like that
sure there's everything he did and they
were they'd beat on me but they would
yeah they would try to rap with me or
whatever rap yeah like talk back and
forth I never got picked on by a girl I
think you did if they liked you you did
I didn't say yeah I kept my mouth shut
maybe I saw it cuz that was the tactic
that was the move it was always like
they're kind of pickling like being
prickly with you and that's the only one
they don't express all like they're like
they're like they slap you in the back
and they run away or like stuff
like that oh yeah I didn't see that as
like getting picked on that's a hell
yeah exactly
you knew immediately yeah that they
liked you know it's the kids that was
like a culture at least if the kids who
over accept it who look at it so
technically that take offense to it like
that's like why would you to slap me
dead like that [ __ ] where it's like oh
my god my name is I doubt today you know
because they're so stupid they didn't
know that the girl like though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]